effort of forum it's just going to have
listened so I need to really emerge you
back evacuation now suppose you know
what happened okay if we're still here
at eleven o'clock I would do if I'd like
through the one minute silence if we are
but similarly feeling but maybe we'll be
finished by then all right go through
this a positive rapson I have counselor
high councilor Hudson Council sparrin
and counsel award are than the others no
non members attending there are now I
mean it's held the meeting on the
thirteenth of July any comments they're
all have agreed to sign okay any
declarations of interest no ok number
five the consultation on licensing act
draft statement of licensing policy I
assume you've all seen red and looked at
it do you want Jen to go through it and
can we try and keep to the main facts of
this document please rather than going
off onto a tangent change you want to
read or do you want to how to stir up
off of the oh I won't know is usually
sort of you better just a second gen do
you want to go through what you want
give used to ask you questions questions
really I'm not even all cheering if
there was any issues that what need to
be rather than after all this is there
any particular issues on it into a dress
that's that's the question are there any
issues on the first one of the
consultation licensing act draft
statement of licensing policy at all
[ __ ] the unmiss once we had was the
lady to sign about the spelling and
within a document but that or go for a
DM you anyway so they'll they'll go
through them look at that we had no
comment on the cumulative impact policy
but with intuition
what a surprise really be specific went
all citizens police and everybody and so
no so that will go ahead as long as full
council agreement and they'll start in
january and she wanted you to explain
immunity back policy a little bit it
just means that when for riley high
street and east it's the road we've
introduced this cumulative impact policy
and any applications once it's in they
will need to demonstrate that having
this business and money miss business
will not impact on the problems that are
already in high street so you know turn
around things like that I've got bittman
I don't want any other business in the
past strokes or so that they all that
but then it was canceled Hudson among
students do see it we've introduced
they've been no comment on it so if it
goes ahead through full council from
January any application they will have
to make sure that he's quiet they have
to be quite pacific on how they're not
going to impact on the problems that
already there and I don't seal mean the
last pub we had was here ago which was
the red door we are getting on
restaurants coming through and the
actual pubs and clubs we haven't had
anything for over a year so I can't see
any premises that would become available
at the moment that would be suitable for
that so it's just that let you know that
we'll be looking at applications in
those areas a living the winning to do
and that was over comment we had all
licensing is this due to the fact of all
this aggravation will be gay regards to
if well it was June I think it would
more came about when basildon close
their knighted up soon we had an influx
of people coming in universe man they
couldn't get in the pubs and clubs
because they were full to capacity or
them turned them away at the door and
they were hanging around
three you know we was having some issues
americana street so it was so that's how
it all came about other than some time
basildon will be open very sona be on
before Christmas so I think that will
deliver we've not seen in the last few
West but it would alleviate the problem
excuse me I thought press again was
opening their new nightclub I've had all
different done so it possibly could be
on for now and we're coming opening in
november or december so that all
different but we've not had any issues
for a while Isis some pizza express how
do we have a license in that picture do
you want to go under any other business
yeah how much strain and new he actually
so yes you think to this yes so is there
any more on this would you going to ask
a question on this may be shy girls
because the scientists can become chali
halter is Christmas not only about the
pitting the compliance if we start
getting out cold rolling on the street
but not whine all these sort of things
these are teleported policy cool yeah
comes under temporary amenities for the
Christmas lights without too
temperamental juices coming in once
Adams which is the funeral parlor up by
PlayStation air force within oh well
they normally do like handle for
somebody to remember on Aging mulled
wine and Squires normally have a store
side and they do mulled wine myself in
the life of sin police officer will be
up down the high street anyway but they
will have to have a temporary me know
she's in the ones that happen they'll be
told to put it away Squires we may put
them on by my gosh girl amateur
attention my money over that okay
the numbers are experiencing does get
busy and yeah just worried about people
drinking delicious the mulled wine isn't
normally very not about younger or two
about things velineon our say it's not
my job to do about that joke yeah I mean
you know if it's some sort of could
happen with a co biet remember the
lemonade also you know whenever really
we're just concerned about the sale of
our home where it's taking place so we
will be patrolling up down anyway just
kidding on that so I remember so
recommendation it is proposed that the
committee recommends to council that the
amended statement of licensing policy
licensing act 203 be approved oh great
Thank You members and the second one is
the consultation I gave me act draft
statement of the licensing policy again
are there any main issues members want
to bring up in this policy / journal
James you want two more pieces of the
air gun here the gambling policy has
been in place since 2005 it's very much
with just when you leave me nobody had
tweaked little bits that come up in
legislation this is Judith even in
between our next January and this
January the Gambling Commission decided
to update the legislation update all
their guidance and then we was thinking
you can't just do this we've got
policies that take time to put in place
so we went on never meeting with again
in addition licensed in offices winner
and they said well no you've just got do
your policy and even though guidance or
not another you know there are many
nations there so unless its licensing
officers decided that what we do is
renew our policy as it stands and then
as the new legislation comes in and the
new guidance comes in we will then sit
down next year we'll give us a time to
go through all the new stuff and then
we'll review the policy next year so
this is really sort of an interim just
to renew the policy so give us time to
go through all the news all the
legislation or removed get and guidance
the new stuff coming in is very much
more local and when we did the gambling
policy it was an essex wide and
wilkinson you know sat down and got it
the epoxy together and 22 severe area
this is very much local we have to do a
local area assessment and we also do
have to do a local area profile plan
which we have to highlight all our
vulnerable premises like schools
churches and alcohol Anonymous meetings
anything like that so it's going to take
me quite a while to do the whole room
area and all the sensitive areas and
this is what we were saying although you
want us to bring this in this year we
haven't got time to do that and then put
the policy in place so that's the reason
why we've renewed it so next year we've
got a meeting after Christmas and we're
gonna go through all of the new stuff a
new guys coming in September so I now
got that so we can go through everything
then and then we'll bring it to you
believe you once we've got the
information it would have put all the
new stuff in any way they've already
tweaked it so it would have done it Mara
this policy would have been to be
reviewed again next year anyway so it
was just it made sense just to renew it
when we've done a couple of it's in
there and just machines you know payouts
and things have been altered or gaming
we did have some comments on it but the
comments are relevant to the new
legislation that will be looking at next
year so i will take those comments take
them into consideration when we're
reviewing them the policy next year but
they're not relevant in this policy look
yeah in things up fully understand it is
it possible when you do dude sit down
and do that is you can let the committee
have some sort of input as to what those
amendments will be before we have a
meeting so that we can take on board
yeah it will be sent out anyway before
it comes to the committee to go out to
consultation so if I get it early enough
i'll send it out early so everybody's
got time to have a little look at in
yeah there are quite significant changes
in it and so mainly they're bringing it
down to everybody doing their own local
and there's quite a lot of
responsibility for the operators like
horror on these people like that and
they're the ones that are commented so
will we take names of consideration as
well but yeah oh cindy an arson early
and everybody can ever look about before
any more comments members so
recommendation on this one is proposed
that the committee recommends to council
that the amended statement of licensing
policy gambling act 2005 be approved and
at the position that the council should
take in respect of casino licenses being
confirmed are we all agreed around of
you okay any photographers gone richard
and is there a ring
if ever I think the casino is a lot of
it you know although you have casino
nights completely different casino
license is for that the biggest eNOS in
south in that way then that's what we
would expect other applications down
softly or another yes yeah you will be
really in the legislation exactly what
it is but that's what we would consider
a concealer casino nights they go on
with determine its not relevant and
pacifica same as we definitely my
recommendation going quickly i engage
your question really of john for
interest up behind her assistant I've
just brought up a point that but people
are the right side going on they
licensed or don't know no there won't be
license because they don't actually deal
with money it's not gambling money
they're like this or they like something
or it will be a fun thing that they will
do a race night it's norm it's not like
gambling where they're actually been you
know like they would you never say
nothing ok maps any anything else want
you to bring up I'll support you into
reality yeah it's not just wondering
about that they on in folks place yeah
I'll do that yet and any other business
and I'll go over a few bits in that
forgets and the other businesses know
they write that right here like a
complete some spruce I think we just
cleared the other question don't yeah
yeah cool and just another young heart
street pizza express has all been a soup
now they're due to open very so not
confirm date on that there will be able
tables and chairs outside the planning
to get past I've reflected that planning
decision in the license so they're not
allowed to be there are market days the
chairs and tigers are not allowed to be
out they have to put it away lemon
o'clock
and the tables and chairs have to be
cleared from the front I can't just
stack them up and leave them outside and
they need to be cleared away so I have
reflected the planning decision for that
pneus for that one those were no vocal
now no don't highways legs thing is
remember not so long ago girl was an
awful lot to do it's been working on yes
ya ain't listenin to work to do it don't
how does it didn't tell me we did you
start busy they do we was about three
weeks ago well it must've worked very
hard today once they get to buy Jack
guys once you get the by CC and then
it's just so they do move pretty quickly
they were very cleanly so again just go
back to the at the front by transmission
so did was soon so do pretty sure I try
to get their fault but they keep talking
about it to market day but then there's
Christmas lights and there are other
occasions where are they required to
take them in there because they are yeah
because mommy stores out there than any
other event Bobby a delivery for example
I mean there was just chocolatier me
yeah so when there's a bit of in shock
will there be so close every requisition
the license says when the markets on and
ten other events during the year and
then uncover yeah I just don't to ten
cans work of you of Sally markets in
this year very clued is there none if
there was any been such as the Olympics
or something huge going on and the place
could put requesting other than she
knows until yet nothing call going out
so the operation the airs operation it's
till eleven o'clock at night I'm not
sure in the morning it's about and in
the morning till 11 and knowledge to
another color
time is along which actually works out
quite well because you know once they
finish that most of the restaurants
finished it 12 the pups are even one on
two and then the club's of story so we
try and stagger oh yeah yeah yeah there
we go David you want a question yeah
it's just a clearly you mentioned that
they have got any land in front it's
highwayman physio do you see they've got
ya they've gotten permission we hear
they have to have as far the application
and um the permission to be there yeah
it was a question when it was pretty
discussed for their planning occupation
as to whether I would need a street
trendy license now spite of the
permission yeah it comes on the pavement
permission to spend on alcohol and
announced a restaurant and Gary that's
why then would that be really good
people because Elliot I've used every
freshman has licensed in the lanes and
would they would there be a restriction
or what they serve there so I don't eat
was simply reply Oh Rosalie yeah it's
part of the licensed area and it's up to
them to manage their premises if the
don't manage their premises then
obviously we would get involved and if
it was necessary for review of the
license and then we would look at taking
their area off the license boys don't
owe me any anything else members when I
used to carry almond yeah yeah yeah and
the Berenson grill which is in the car
park over here and that's going to be
like an American diner oh and here
that's the license has been issued for
that he's looking drug napped for
christmas as well that's the only
applications we've got in at the moment
and we have managed to get funding for
taxi marshals on the taxi rank from the
eleven o'clock till four o'clock on a
friday and saturday night they've been
in for the last couple of weeks there's
obviously been a few teething problems
because the guys are getting used to it
and but we know quite positive feedback
from the taxi drivers and for all
the pub's pub watch is going really well
we've got 42 people banned from rally at
the moment for us two years they miss
behind they're very very on board with
this as well they're very good at
bringing people to task if they're
misbehaving threatening the staff and on
street as well you know if they know who
it is they've come and they've been from
their premises and they've managed to
identify and then they will ban them we
did at some training on your pod we did
two days of training and which included
and drugs conflict management we are
training standards there and we had
children sexual exploitation oh yeah as
well as writing and we are very positive
again i embody that we had a four-hour
drug session and included legal highs as
well and all the information they needed
on legal highs as well so that was quite
public that one we're looking to do that
going next year we did it last year so
I'm going to try and do it every year
the licensees just first question that
can that train you not be done for
councils of an evening rather than the
daytime with some people who work that
meets or thing continously come to all
have to have half days holiday and
something recurring us it's not very
shining so it tend to do it in the
morning because they have to open their
there pops and premises and they like
this staff to come back now I'm just
think of cancers I'm thinking account
since I've not necessary outside people
if you want to send them out so I'm
feeling good but i'm justing of people
you know Fras of an evening of our
session that was already yeah we
probably could be conventional I would I
we think I'd be quite interesting to do
that
we put the new legislation in place but
again but the alconbury also like from
the game yesterday which is which is
really really good observing two days of
work yeah it was really were very
natural city was very impactful losing
to police that it was because a lot of
place and they do visits for sleight
realizes he visits that was very
infamous in a lot information from them
last a couple other people who worked in
pubs and balances so she was really
lovely because you have a variety of
people there and it was full yeah but I
just think for the counselors it be but
a good idea for an obsession on the
other sessions you've had I just think
it'd be good for us because that was
four hours that's a long time i'm
justing a two hours but we got yeah I
would be too long is doing a new
character no I'm just anxious for two
hours not take our whole lot ya gotta do
Shaun spoils compile a beautiful without
the place own kind of that place I mean
but with the closures in a cup action of
it grows on how is that affecting
licensing is a problem for you um not at
the moment it's not and we've got a
really good licensing police officers
they've greener we work very close
together speak to Steve every day on any
issues that are going on monday that I'm
a meeting with the notices there was any
issues then we'll go out visit and find
out what's going on we've got a very
good working relationship Republican
really it's one of the big one is the
best pub watching ethics we've got here
at the mug then they've all got radios
no keeping contact and we also got an
app on their phone I'm and often goes
off at two in the morning but you know
just 11 though somebody's coming down
the high street you know we just started
about you mind
one let in so the communication in high
street and with the place is very very
good in a moment I've been assured we're
not gonna lose think greener we are
losing PCSOs and please note at the
moment go lay out and probably assassin
or how two o'clock so we may see a
difference there because they're not
going to be out once once they all go
that could be an issue but then that's
why we introduced the taxi marshals and
as I say we've got publish our money now
so well leading to that one and I think
it's a vendor's issue is we're not that
pretty relevance to employment but
certainly if we and the contractors
curry company for example to have visits
on behalf of license 95 well you do need
sensing of a cell phone pick up the
visits we don't have to it will do that
if I mean if that becomes a strange an
issue could you bring that back to
Memphis because I think we've got to
keep ignoring these things and I could
bring it back to issue if is initially
yeah obviously we're not going to be
visiting as many as language we will
visit obviously the places that we see
could have an issue which is what we
used to do every month we obviously
given us to the police and people that I
wanted to places I wanted him to visit
but they're handy bit about that is they
would go out of an evening they would go
out up a night I work for my in the
morning and it means if I have to go out
till two in the morning you know been my
day job suffers really and there's only
me doing the last 16 so it couldn't oh I
will keep you updated it could be an
issue the delicious idea if I might tim
jenny because when we were together you
are you register be as s all i would use
a security we've got your fans
good fun but I mean I'm sure I'm not
like this I'm sure there are other
members on a cycle that that's not
everybody's cup of tea but especially
mainly who wouldn't mind if they were
authorized to just go out and just if I
found issues that could be pulled back
but not confronting advantage of an
advocate but perhaps that's something we
could look at where members and if they
were registered could publish your and I
now a very prevalent it before any
they'll come out there where when I
wants a casa point difficult to get psi
and coming still the doorman they are
very good that very good contact and I
was willing to come out of joints for
the smoker thing mainly outdoor man are
in railing and as same as we are as
close to a pub watch we are with their
Norman as well because it now all
talking to one another we've got the
radios with one another and we're
finding now that with the premises in
radio if they've got any show they'll
come to us now rather than try and
highly or sweep down to the carpet if
they have a problem on a Saturday nine
nine out 10 times your enemies think so
got an issue center tonight the own room
home and I myself not get what happens
and then tell me what happens and we'll
go through it now our way of looking at
is we want to work together with them
yes we're enforcement and if it comes to
it yes we will enforce but to work with
them and get to talk to us has been
invaluable it really adds on that fly
straight and you know and they will look
out for stuff as well you know we've got
dorling that were there's an agreement
with the police now the if there's an
issue in se1 premises then we assess
their own premises leave one dorm and go
and help so they can go from two to six
in all right so Kailyn tutor 60 seconds
and it's not happened it happens when we
add the issue at bar Blanco year before
last when I was five there know when
trans and helped with that one we also
look when the incidents help how the
premises has managed to their never not
going to have any incidents because it's
just you have an H other guy but we go
in and look at the CCTV I'm going to
look how to start for the management
handle the incident how they managed it
you know anything me and the police they
managed it very well which that's fine
you've managed it you've managed to
separate it in groups and do know Jack's
a policeman what they need to do if
they're not managed it very well then we
will work with them if necessary they'll
be able to view of the license they've
really felt if not then we can work with
them get an extra training whether they
need really there's no matter of working
in partnership really I'm into tears
bowling but I'm not aware of any of
serious issues now that hasn't been for
a while I don't keep going babe birds
are no way of anything seriously yeah I
mean even the active shoes in this
summer time as in the haight street but
people get internal body that's the
problem because they either were too
drunk enough wouldn't let them in the
premises although afford to capacity and
couldn't let in so they were getting
frustrated because I'm coming into the
town unless if you can't get in anywhere
here there's nowhere else to go this was
not properly as I've done it
darling because he doesn't like that
section vulnerable because they will see
somewhere else to go you know to me yeah
and I do see there's a bundle of
anybody's going by but that's what I am
appreciator just an update I've got for
you we've got a meeting with whole
bridge were trying to sell pub watching
home which you're going to include hawk
wall and hopefully we're struggling to
get them on board it's not something we
can we can they have to study out the
self and we support so the work has to
come from them so we've got a couple of
people on board so the hope it will be
chairman and social and then they can
generally not get the others together
and from meeting this week and then we
will go enjoy certain public on you say
yeah yeah holdrege papi I knew on man
I'm tearing everything for fun parachute
on as you say they're very reluctant to
do it themselves there was one somebody
else to do it I found the clapping the
same with halibut footpaths of technical
is how bridgend they have to do it but
we're trying to get the joint venture
with them and something they're
interested somebody else to do it and
they say yeah yeah yeah I gotta be
failed oh yeah it's a shame but that's
the way and engine is ok but we need the
trouble is you need two Republic's to
work you need all the premises to be on
board it's no good banning amount of
Sherman and they can go in the others so
you know we need them to be when I don't
do you and work together what Las do you
do we get many problems it's a pulsing
hope I'm talking for mums with my hockey
the moment do we get him big promising
cult in hockley only got not only aware
[ __ ] hope we're not aware around five
if we set one up in whole bridge and we
said we've already got our one here
they're being bands where they're going
to go yeah and you know this is the
problem that pushes them to another area
and that's what we don't want is cushion
at that one of them to be aware that
wasn't happening here as well judges oh
it's involved that they all use together
all the different places in these are
places yes I've got the so-called
nightclub no now's the house thank you
by challenging people that have been
banned from people that have been banned
from Riley actually live in hullbridge
we've had a few new remote bridge
hockley you know so it is their local
people as well since they can't go out
with their friends here there are two
other in order to serve him well what
happens is the Chairman's will get
together so from sale friendly basildon
castle point all the Chairman's get
together and if they've got anybody that
they've been for two years that is you
know drug dealer or particularly violent
they will bring that to all the pub
watches and they'll ban them all the way
around also the market i like how do you
serve design and detail tell you stuff
if you do the same thing do so i think
the police doing that that comes under
although we have pub watch that comes
under the place or yeah they deliver the
letters they collect them have to sign
for them and they call me out a public
display they have to be calm
I'm staff and they're very because of
data protection they have to be so yeah
they're very very common problem so do
you notify the ones we've all given
those outlandish areas about people who
are bound doing these places not the
moment cuz I've got prob watch it's only
pub watchman member you don't like I
have individual in Ireland they have to
be in a pub watch scheme or saying hang
out go to catania written about how much
n yeah we've got waiting this week and
when we're hoping they're going to turn
up bacan but everyone knows you can't
Michael that's it would be nice if they
have one representative of each because
we tryna do you tryna get you trying to
go Barbara Pierre do you speak to the
restaurant as we're just a pub just the
pups we don't do question we don't we
fine we don't get the problems in
restaurants cuz the reaching under a big
nose you've got I'm just also thinking
about some the one in hot curry which is
at bar was it called I know in me was it
called a boring Harrison's no no no how
is it well that's a restaurant no the
one that shot right in hot creasing in
hot clearance or 10 graphic Bertha when
it all changed its name S&E yeah one
mighty engine hot clear and he actually
bar big was scented my toes on his
license there is a condition sign he
needs to be a member of her watch but he
hasn't got pub watch that's the problem
we need to set up or charm so then we
can get them all on board the condition
will only you know say if there is a
public in the area and there's North so
that's what we're trying to do at the
moment what replied you get from the
like the spar or the pub's doing silence
not at all you might think and you're
gonna get to talk to them at all either
we can't go out it's for whoever's on
the vampire you know this is the problem
because for us we could go visit explain
every
but we can't be seen leading it we have
to just hope it's been very good ething
very good little lady hopefully
especially so if you've got and Rakim
can she help yes I mean she can leave it
as a her husband can lead it got their
own good yeah but could they go to the
other place yes young people because
she's very keen and she wants him very
very good club doesn't shame she comes
just going on to that is she not really
dirty I don't be shooting when she make
it she may be able to get one of the
other one where I say of the closest to
go forward and I mean I'm not
necessarily I don't think she'll be able
to maybe else okay somebody else going
forward and we did have a prayer pub
watching hullbridge but unfortunately
with these premises when somebody leaves
the next person takes over it doesn't
always support me when we know we've got
quite stable you know nicest things here
yeah rightly so you know we will try
when will try and get it together and
i'll keep you updated as well fine okay
i need together and get all three any
other anything else so gentle I can see
my whole girl we got a question or
attempted emotions and their large my
job is I don't once i'm at the doorman
and they're employed to organize the
cure for taxes because we was fighting
we was getting few jump in and then
there was fights about getting in taxis
taxis were getting damaged so their move
managed to get funding actually to light
prom so very important body they're
employed by us it's erm the Community
Safety Partnership and that's where the
fundings come through
it was on the report one of the taxi
licensing that came out of everybody
yeah so there were some sort of unity
ball together and they love their own
bands on going to check them all myself
and out the door be open for people
wishing for attacks independence and yes
yes yes they're aware that they're out
the other words and they're working what
that's working quite well apartment blue
okay ma'am this is that anything else at
all many other questions any of the
right and you're stranded just to let
you know there's we've got sexual
entertainment venues open south ends
we've now got one on mana trading estate
in benfleet as well we haven't had any
applications as yet but that is part of
our remit so just to make you aware that
you know then we're gonna trade
interstate squire the way you know jack
done it's quite out the way but they did
since they seem to be looking now places
like this and it's now they've just been
issued a license for it to be a night
club as well so the days it's not a
novice sexual entertainment venue they
can use is a nightclub so they look to
separate license is now include this is
a bit limited air right in their
district well you don't need something
that's happening
or entertainment yes industry Mike you
lien make you aware that they are satin
amends so when you say she actually the
table is your column dancing that's
whole dancing lap dancing strippers no
Jack you'll not go no site business that
happen outside has been outside of it
only when we can do this i admit i leave
very sheltered just boys day our main
concern because if you go down Brook for
example she's ours we've got mushroom
theater company so you've got young
people we would i would have great
objections today for starters it's just
some of your aware that they're not just
in the nine tails they are you know
beginning to hmm so you know obviously
you'll be aware of you get an
application and everybody knows yes let
you know that my elders thought it was
easy no we don't know ever cattle appear
to be sorry go on I'm sorry going at the
time just another one we are having
managed to get funding the gun for some
training for the taxi drivers and that
will be on disability awareness and
we're doing it on child sex works
plantation and prevent so we're doing
sorry we're just in the early stages now
I'm meeting with the disability
awareness trying to thursday i'm working
with brian and community safety to try
to get other trainers for those edges of
the taxi license in People v a taxi
drivers for this but for those issues
really fun and they've got a lot of book
trio accessible vehicles but we're
finding that they're reluctant to take
disabled people in wheelchairs and it
may be that they've not had the proper
training so the others deal with that
it's not just wheelchairs you know its
people with arthritis
a lot of the assistant dogs now it's not
just for the blind there's different
assistant box as well so it really
didn't mean deliver you know you're only
non this room jackknives I did it over
in casa point it will be managed to
trick was the only way we can get in is
to make it mandatory again that'd be
nice on for the counter or not and we've
done it you've been off of the council's
again just to get an idea what I don't
know if counsel can go on it or whether
we at game we can see I have no training
course yeah yeah or what i can do is let
you know what chinese out there and then
you let me know what you want then I
can't think it's a good idea when I was
something you're gonna sail how many
charity drives them you got we've got
319 so would've lit new hole well I've
got to find it and I've got to find a
venue that's all in early stages of monk
but it's gonna have to be over six
sessions because there's some many of
them yeah yeah i would sell weekly being
included then yes we have one o'clock if
you wanted to be in cody but they will
probably be dying because of their work
yeah that's fine but carol suggested but
your time I ever gave you I can't come
into baby no no I care i'm gonna go kept
i'm awful at all i want to leave it be
not have anything further member my face
I think each photo jobs I mean any
dependency for though your garage now
we've got independence as well if it's
manager Jack don't have to because it's
their license that's why we've got to
doing that white blue and they'll be
told this is free training and if you
don't attend you will have to pay for
you around training and that normally
might overwhelm a known and your fake
down to Train attend what happens in
well then we would look at them all know
if improper person okay that's fine
forgive my ignorance but um that we got
transportation money Jimmy no Jill I'm
sorry place washing up yeah I mean she's
a cenar lose I'm the senior licensing
officer at the moment cliff is admin and
mike is the enforcement and but I
understand it's just being restructured
they're talking about restructuring sow
is allowing yourself as transport
why don't you be manager because it just
got rid of a manager yeah I do have been
important taxis now you know now you
have an important licensing but it's
very difficult for us that you train run
because I'm so busy I just haven't got
time sit down with the licensing you
don't pick up in a day you know it's a
week and I just haven't had the time
I've been so busy who are you lady
antigen law because this was an issue of
watches to the water now I'm concerned
we might be kinda show too much better
bug I think I think most of us are even
I was on that committee because though
we done trimming too thin that's why I
mentioned about if there was a need that
name if that needs to be brought back
because we enforcement's a big issue yes
anyway I just like that point below
things you can bring up in review maybe
no I don't know let's interview and I
was just in the process of restructuring
us can find out what I don't you get
more more legislation there aren't yours
in already what we don't do is get
absorbed and swallowed up into there's a
big abyss yeah safety advisor group
takes up a lot more time with the ads or
events because we've got such a lot of
omean spices I do spend a lot of time on
the safety advisory group and deemed
outdoor
and we have a huge problem with after
prom parties particularly in early in
the year and because these parents will
just stick up the marquee they'll have a
bunch of kids and they're all drinking
they'll be parents searching them you
know so we have to try be on top and try
and get the scores before we're looking
with well I'm talking about when we say
braid out I think we're going to be
going to the secondary schools and
talking to the the Paris associations
we've been talking to about what they
need to put any event on what licenses I
need will they need to do about
searching drinking underage you know
they're not allowed to drink under 18
you cannot no matter what event is you
cannot let them do hemorrhoids and and
we had a particular one all crouched by
the showground and at four o'clock in
the morning and they let mom out on the
a12 45 okay wandering out now and
they're drunk you know it sees them
issues that we're trying to get on top
of because we don't get notice if
they're not licensed there we don't get
notice of it so and then it just happens
so we're trying to get the message out
to schools and parents to say if you're
thinking of putting this on it's great
you're doing an office burdening up
they'll love it but please put these
measures in place on and that's
something else we saw work appreciated
you get a problem because of us no one
knows yeah so what you send that the
answers have problems in this country
now oh god oh very bright and
helicopters are students there is only
look in every secondary school you've
got here in this area has a problem and
we get prompts from other areas here so
a lot of them yeah they'll do me a bowl
on
they'll have a phone and someone a
marquee up on a farm they'll be in seven
schools will come off from we do yet
yeah
okay members i think this is that all
jack i'll try and pick update it cones
cual about on the north sea level okay
I'm closing the meeting in at 10 42 and
thank you all very much for coming today
and